hi everyone in this video we're going to
talk about somatic hypermutation so as
the name suggests somatic hypermutation
means a mutation process and the somatic
also indicates that this mutation
process is confined in somatic cells and
the mutation is not in the germ cells
that means the mutation is confined in
one generation and doesn't transmit from
one generation to other generation
overall somatic hypermutation is the
process of generation of antibody
diversity so definitely the site of
somatic hypermutation is the
immunoglobulin gene segments the DNA
which encodes for immunoglobulin gene so
that is basically the site for somatic
hypermutation now somatic hypermutation
leads to small changes in at the DNA
level and these changes are depicted
here now the somatic hypermutation is
augmented by specific enzymatic
machinery such as activity induced cited
in thea - now this mutation apparatus
ultimately allows mutation which would
lead to several changes in the antibody
affinity now there could be antibodies
which are having high affinity and some
antibodies which are having low affinity
the high affinity antibody would be
favored and selected but the cells which
are having low affinity antibody as
their b-cell receptor those would be
eliminated so this is the overview now
let's talk about this process in with
more details so our body is always
getting exposed to several pathogens
such as viruses bacteria and many other
and our body's immune system produce
antibodies against this viral or
bacterial antigens now let's say this is
a virus and there are specific
antibodies which are produced right
these antibodies are against the
specific Spike protein now we have to
understand these viruses are evolving
very rapidly and they change
their strain now their spiked proteins
are different the antibodies which are
produced before are no more able to they
are not able to recognize the spiked
proteins anymore now there is always a
constant battle between the antibody
producing cells and the pathogens for
who can recognize whom right
if the antibodies which are generated by
the plasma cells are not able to
recognize the pathogen then the pathogen
gets advantages so mutational changes in
both the sides could give advantage to
each of them now we will talk about how
mutational change in B cells can give
advantage to our immune system and
that's all about the somatic
hypermutation and we are going to talk
about where does somatic hypermutation
occur what is the mechanism behind
somatic hypermutation and finally what
is the benefit of somatic hypermutation
so all of these questions we need to
understand so first let's start with
where does somatic hypermutation take
place so we all know that immature
b-cells eventually reach the lymph lymph
node which is like an army base camp and
they are deployed there for temporary
time right now in the lymph node there
are specific regions such as b-cell
follicles and the cortical area where T
cells and B cells reside now the B cell
area is basically the b-cell follicles
and inside the B cell follicles the B
cells develop proliferate and mature
right so the B cell can undergo rapid
proliferation in this zone they can also
get differentiated to plasma cells all
of these things happen in this molecule
your area now let's say t-cell and
b-cell are interacting in the
intermediate zone between these two and
the T cell gives activity signal to the
B cell and the B cell would ultimately
be differentiated into antibody
secreting plasma cells right
it would also undergo significant amount
of proliferation and ultimately
actually that would produce plasma cells
now we have to understand this process
in bit more details a lot of factors are
taken into account in this process so
the B cells which have reached the B
cell follicle they would eventually
proliferate but they would be later on
selected for their affinity towards an
antigen now let's say a B cell have very
low affinity towards an antigen then
this B cell won't be favored how it is
possible we will talk about it but this
B cell won't be favored it would be dead
via apoptotic mechanism now let's say
some B cells which have very low
affinity but sometimes what happens
there are mechanisms by which the B cell
receptor can be edited and corrected for
its affinity if the correction is
successful then the low affinity problem
is rectified and they would ultimately
get differentiated to plasma cell or
proliferate more there is other
possibilities there are processes like
somatic hypermutation which is our
discussion topic today well my new
changes in the IG gene segments can lead
to differential affinity in the
receptors and the low affinity ones are
dead whereas the high affinity ones are
selected and they get the chance to
differentiate into plasma cells and
eventually even after that they undergo
a process called class switching which
we would talk in the next video so let's
talk about the mechanism of somatic
hypermutation we already have looked at
that where somatic hypermutation take
place the location and it is a lymph
node in the beef cell follicles area
right now let's talk about the mechanism
so the key enzyme that is important for
somatic hypermutation is activation
induced cited in deaminase so this
enzyme converts the Aqsa site diene to
deoxy yuri team so you can see our
deamination process is taking place here
right so what is the consequence of that
so whenever there is a deamination of
the sighting there would be a mismatch
of g2u right so let's look at this
process in details so this is the basic
segment of the DNA which is not mutated
yet after the active activity of AI D
there is a c2 you transition and this
lead to a miss pairing into you versus G
right and from there on there could be
different mechanisms which can generate
mutations for example first there would
be replication of these strands now at
the end of one replication cycle there
would be a particular DNA strand which
would be having a versus T bonding
rather than GC so this particular strand
is totally mutated right this particular
DNA segment is totally mutated and these
cells which are undergoing somatic
hypermutation they are also dividing
rapidly so replication induced mutation
incorporation is pretty frequent in them
other than that other than the
replication mechanism there could be
also activity of uridine glycosylase and
short patch base excision repair
mechanism which might lead to lot of
changes at the genetic level there could
be also mismatch repair system followed
by repairing with a faulty DNA
polymerase or our error-prone DNA
polymerase which might incorporate
mutations in the gene segment so all of
these mutations are pretty much random
but ultimately the immune system selects
for those mutations which lead to
increase in affinity so the rate of the
somatic hypermutation is several order
of magnitude higher in the variable
region of the antibody genes compared to
the CIM compared to the constant region
or any other gene segment so the
question is why is so that the hotspot
of somatic hypermutation is limited to
the variable region of the
immunoglobulin genes now it all
so leads to several questions such as
how the activity of a ID is restricted
or more pronounced in case of variable
region of immunoglobulin genes also we
have to understand that is there any
specific mechanism which is directing
these mutational apparatus specifically
to the variable region DNA segment and
not to other places so these questions
has bothered scientists for a long time
and the answer came from sequencing
results when scientists looked at the
sequence of the variable region
carefully they identified one sequence
motif shown in red this sequence motifs
are enriched in the variable region and
not in other places that means this
sequence motif is guiding the mutational
apparatus to this specific region and
that is why the mutation is more
pronounced or the effect of the mutation
is more pronounced in the weight
variable region genes segments compared
to other places and later on it is also
discovered that the segments which
undergo class switching those region
also have this characteristic segments
which guide the AI dee' to that location
it is amusing amazing that AI D can lead
to somatic hypermutation as well as it
can help in class switching reactions in
next video we're going to talk about
class switching so we pretty much
understand how somatic hypermutation
take place now let's look at what is the
advantage of somatic hypermutation
somatic hypermutation leads to change in
affinity of these b-cells right or the B
cell receptors
now these b-cell receptors which have
increased affinity they are better in
terms of recognizing antigens presented
on follicular dendritic cell so look at
this particular B cell this particular B
cell has undergone somatic hypermutation
and its affinity has increased
dramatically so it can really
out-compete another b-cell who has low
affinity as a result what is happening
the cells which has low B seer affinity
they are dying and they would undergo
apoptosis and the
B cells which has a higher affinity
towards the antigens would eventually
out-compete and they would survive
proliferate and ultimately differentiate
into antibody secreting plasma cells so
this is the overall advantage of somatic
hypermutation the overarching aspect of
somatic hypermutation is to generate
diversity in terms of antigen antibody
interaction so that is a key goal of
this process so just to summarize in
this video we have looked at where does
somatic hypermutation take place and we
have looked at that in the germinal
Center in the b-cell follicle inside the
spleen and lymph node the somatic
hypermutation can take place and in
terms of molecular biology we looked at
what is the mechanism of somatic
hypermutation what are the enzymatic
involvement in somatic hypermutation we
have also looked at what is the
advantage of somatic hypermutation and
how somatic hypermutation helps to
generate antibody diversity so I hope
this video was useful to you guys if you
like this video give it a quick thumbs
up don't forget to Like share and
subscribe and do let me know in the
comment how do you like my videos and if
you have a question feel free to ask in
the comment section thank you guys